if george st pierre
and khabib nurmagomedov face each other
in their prime who wins
cool that's it very very loaded
questions how yeah like what are the
different trajectories you see
okay how does each one win in your view
if one wins or the other one with what
happens interestingly they're actually
very similar in size despite the fact
that
george fought at welterweight and could
be fought at a lightweight if you
actually see them stand next to each
other they're of similar height khabib's
actually a little more thick set
yeah he's actually heavier than you
walking around um
george walked around most of his career
between 188 and
191 pounds
and so khabib actually would ironically
have
a kind of size and strength advantage uh
despite being in the lighter weight
division that's been the general trend
as mma
has grown is that athletes will come
further down and wait to make weight
divisions um
uh
i believe that george has the best
takedowns in history
uh in the open in the cage
um khabib was his great strength was
using the fence
to facilitate takedowns
um
khabib's
other great strength was not only his
ability to take people down but to keep
people down for extended periods of time
both of them were
powerful strikers on the ground and
could do terrible damage to opponents
on the floor so
they're both very similar in that regard
khabib was mostly a
puncher from the back george is mostly
an elbow from the front
but both of them could lay waste to
opponents with strikes on the floor
um both of them were highly competent
with submissions on the ground they
weren't submission specialists in the
sense of someone like gordon ryan but uh
they were
certainly um
no slouches with submission holds
um
yeah it's just a fascinating idea so
it's almost like who gets the first take
down yeah i do believe
that
they could probably stand up on each
other
i don't think either one of them would
be able to hold the other down for a
whole round
um both of them are notoriously
difficult people to hold down so i don't
think that whoever won the first date
and wins the match i don't think it's
like that
um i do believe that george would hold a
decisive advantage in striking and
distance management
um the few times that khabib did look
shaky as
when he
could be was either advancing forward
menacingly but when he had to
to fight moving backwards
there was a definite asymmetry between
his ability to fight going forwards
which is very good and his ability to
fight going backwards which was
noticeably
weaker
um george would often fight both
forwards and backwards with the thiago
elvis fight
most of the standing time yeah was was
going backwards
um
that's
probably the the single biggest
difference between that two athletes and
skill level would be in the standing
position
um
on the ground uh
khabib slight edge and takedowns on the
fence george slight edge and takedowns
in the center
um ability to inflict damage on the
floor roughly equal ability to fight off
the back roughly equal
ability to stand up from bottom roughly
equal it's a very very hard match
in terms of the biggest
difference and skill level is going to
be in a standing position and so it
would come down to
that doesn't necessarily mean that
khabib would lose in the standing
position he might just push it to the
fence and just use match tactics where
he
kept the fight on the fence for
significant periods of time
and you can win rounds in that fashion
so it's a match that could go either way
both of them are
absolutely the best that you'll ever see
i've always believed the three greatest
mixed martial artists i've ever seen in
my life were
george st pierre khabib nurmagomedov and
jon jones
the three of them have some interesting
similarities and differences
all three
beat every single person they ever faced
i i know john jones officially has lost
by dq but no one believes that was a
loss um
uh george does have two losses but he
uh
defeated both athletes decisively uh in
rematches gabe did it by having no
losses interestingly all three athletes
have at least one match which is
controversial in terms of who won and
who lost um
uh jon jones has had several matches
which could have gone either way on the
judge's scorecard khabib's uh
match against grayson tebow could have
gone either way
george's match with hendricks was could
have gone either way they all had
matches that they won which people would
dispute the outcome so that was a
similarity between the three of them
um
all three of them
have had the ability
to dominate the direction of fights when
they want it to go down it goes down
when they don't want it to go down it
doesn't
um
that's why i put such a heavy emphasis
on that idea that a mixed martial arts
champion must be able to determine the
direction of a fight it's the single
most important attribute that they all
must have
um
as to which of the three
is the best it's going to come down to
criteria
you you can't pull them apart
which answer you give as to which of
those three is the greatest of all time
will come down to the criteria that you
use
okay is it being undefeated
um uh is it the amount of time was it
the quality of the opponents that they
had if you do it by quality of opponents
i think you probably have to give it to
george if you do it by
um uh measured dominance through not
being defeated then it has to go to
compete
um
arguably you could say the same with jon
jones since his one
losses
by dq but then you could also say the
last three or four fights that john's
had haven't been the same measure of
dominance as we saw previously so
ultimately
you've got those three guys in my
opinion
and which one you choose will come down
to who it says more about who you are as
a viewer than it does about the
respective level of the athletes you
could throw a blanket over them the
three of them are just that good and um
uh and which one you select will
probably say more about who you are as a
viewer than it does about them
as athletes